Quick update on what it's been like living with my boyfriend.
We moved in, it's been like July, August,
September. So it's been two months now.
And we moved in with the, like,
the idea of like a village.
If he's not my kids stepdad,
he calls them roommates. Um,
he doesn't. You know
that it was.
I think a lot of people did,
and a lot of people did make comments about like,
how the fuck you gonna live with somebody
and they're not gonna be helping you with your kids and blah, blah, blah.
But for me personally, I just don't want somebody.
I don't. I don't wanna co parent with that many people.
I just don't think it's necessary.
I don't think my kids need more adults talking to them in their life,
so. But because we've never pushed for relationships to build
and because it's just everybody's respected,
everybody space.
This past weekend, I was having an issue with one of my children,
and I promised one of my other children
that I would take them to the park.
And so I was like,
I can't be into places at once.
And you can't provide my child the comfort that they need,
cause they need it from their mom.
Would you mind taking my other kids to the park for me?
Like, I am.
They just want to go to the park.
So if I just explain, like,
Kyle will take you to the park,
you Know, they.
I know they'd be happy. And he was like,
yeah, sure.
Happy to help. He took my kids to the park for way longer than, like,
almost, like,
an hour. They were at the park,
they played and had fun.
Then Saturday, we all just hung out,
a really nice time. And then on Sunday,
my daughter with a disability,
she had a birthday party with one of the kids in her class.
So this wasn't just a birthday party.
This was a birthday party
of all children that have a developmental disability.
You know, sometimes that can be a hard,
you know, a lot to take in.
And I was like, if I take her to the birthday party,
the other kids are gonna be sad that they're staying home.
But I can't be in two places at once.
They didn't invite all my kids.
Like, would you want to come with us?
But you would kind of have to hang out with them in the arcade part,
like, while I'm in the birthday party,
because you know what I mean?
I was trying to be polite.
Of the birthday party, but everybody,
it was like, yeah,
not only did we go to the fucking arcade,
he's like, oh,
I just bought a card for the kids.
They're playing, they're having fun.
And I was like, oh, okay.
And then when we were all hanging out and, like,
playing video games, one of us,
one Of my daughter said she was hungry,
and I was like, okay.
So I took her to, like,
the little area that was a Dave and Busters.
I took her to the little area to sit down,
and he sat down with us, and then he ordered a few things,
and then he paid for everything.
And I was like,
did you just take me and my children out to Dave and Busters?
Like, super cash?
Like, no big deal.
What? And then we came home.
And then we came home and he cooked dinner.
What?
It was like the sweetest little weekend.
It was so nice. And it feels like everybody's, like,
little relationships are starting to form and grow naturally with no,
like, weirdness.
It's nice. We're all kind of getting into a rhythm.
I feel like all the conflict we kind of had when we first moved in
was truly just because of the stress of moving.
But it really feels like we're settling into a nice little normal.
Um. I'm not at all trying to say that life is perfect,
but I am really trying to drive home the point that
you do not need to stay in a miserable marriage.
You do not need to stay for the kids.
The kids fucking know that your.
Your marriage is miserable.
And the kids are probably thinking,
I wish mum and dad would get a fucking divorce already.
So, um.
And then when you do get a Divorce.
You'll be happy again. Life doesn't end because you got a divorce.